foreign
but to say jesus
does it mean something you first of all
you would never sweep yeah i am good
it's just that it would never no you
might say
because the question is come on
how are you it's all about going come on
how is it going
uh come over to which is like kamota
levu
then the answer would be
yeah i am going well
i mean you if you said yeah this people
understand you but it's not normally now
again i'm not a native speaker maybe
there's a french native speaker here who
will jump in and say no no we say that
but to me
come on come on
so the verb in the question is how are
you going come over to so the answer is
i'm going fine
okay great
question
do you understand that
uh-huh that means do you know that's a
way of saying you know like
it's like a oh
it's just a filler
i always miss hearing it there's a lot
of words that sound just like sit and
friends oh yeah absolutely that's that's
one of the difficulties in french so say
see a posture v-e-s-t it is
said
say just say i know
so yeah those are some of the things and
then of course uh
yeah and c e like this oh sure
sir
don't get your spanish sneaking in there
e without an accent is so
well
now say as in
it's like
these
books say leave
okay
but say and say is different
s
s e s t or j
whereas
is more like saying something in english
not quite as much but but these are
things you gradually get used to and you
you
you're able to pick them out from the
context
anyway tell me before we get i have a
few things in mind that i wanted to go
over with you but are there any
questions or problems that you are
experiencing with your french that you
would like to raise
um
i think it's just that
being able to
um
identify
i mean i'm still really working on my
pronunciation right
and unders and come and comprehension
as well so
i've been practicing saying you know
like on the many stories
answering the questions out loud
sometimes just like repeating them
um i've been importing some song lyrics
into link
and so i've been trying to actually sing
along oh yeah um
and i've been um i started le petit
ponce
for the first four chapters okay
and
it's it's really helpful because i've
already read that book in spanish okay
so like a couple years ago so i kind of
know what's going on and i think that's
also been helping me
um so i've just been experimenting with
different methods of of learning right
um
i guess i we've talked a little bit
about
when to practice vocabulary and i'll be
honest i haven't done really like any
vocabulary practice this week
um
which i know you wanted me to do i think
it would be nice to
i think show people like what your
preferred method is if you're doing
vocab right because i see people who do
a lot of different
ways of practicing it okay like would
you ever recommend to just go to the
full list of vocabulary and do it that
way or do you only like to do it in the
lessons i rarely do that
uh
again i think it's good to explore
because we all need to take charge of
our own learning so the fact that you're
exploring different content that's good
that means you know you have to maintain
your curiosity obviously the the many
stories provide a lot of repetition
and
but then you get bored with those and so
you need to go and explore other content
it's also absolutely true that the more
familiar we are with the content the
better we're gonna learn
so if you were gonna do i don't know if
you are knowledgeable in nuclear physics
or something but if you were to read
something in french about nuclear
physics you wouldn't have much of a
chance i wouldn't if i were doing that
in persian because i know nothing about
the context but if you go to something
like the little prince lupti
where you're familiar with it
obviously it's easier it's easier you're
familiar with it so
yeah so that's a good thing to do with
regard to vocabulary review
i typically do it as i turn the page
and um my preferred
method would be just to look at a list
like to be perfectly honest i don't have
the patience to go through flash cards
and if i go through flash cards i go
through quickly i want all the
information on the front of the flash
card it's just exposure bing bing bing
bing bing
and i would prefer actually i've told
mike this i would prefer just to see a
list every page as i turn the page i
look at a list of all the words that
were there with their meaning right
there just a quick summary of what i saw
and then i move on to the next page
uh i have on occasion and i think it's
sometimes useful because again we like
to vary the things that we do
so to go to the vocabulary section at
link
and you know
for in russian i was tagging things
because the case endings are so
difficult so then i would review
everything that i tagged for the
accusative case or that i a tag for the
instrumental case so i review those in
sort of concentrated form
anytime you get a concentration of
something of examples i find that
helpful so another thing that i would
sometimes do and you may want to do at
some point in your french is go to the
vocabulary section which is normally
organized alphabetically and that's me
that means that
words that you have saved that are very
closely related that begin with the same
letter that have the same
you know components in them you're gonna
see four five six of them and that helps
you begin it's a concentrated form you
know
i can't remember you know
conditions
so you would get a whole bunch of these
words that are somewhat related and you
have saved them all separately
maybe because you didn't remember what
they meant or because you wanted the
different forms of them and then if you
look on your
vocabulary list i find the alphabetical
review
on a totally sort of
random basis is sometimes a fun thing to
do just to
you know introduce some variety in in
your learning but most of my time is
listening and reading i don't do a lot
of dedicated vocabulary review
i find flashcards boring and annoying
and so that's me but there are people
who enjoy doing that so it's not safe
do you always
use tags when you make links
no
it depends on the language i found the
tags really helpful
um so at different stages like when i
started into arabic or persian like
everything is a blur
when i listen it's a blur and and i'm
not really sure what's a verb what's a
noun
and so i started i would tag it this is
a noun this is a verb so that i can then
look at all the verbs together look at
the nouns together but that's only at
the beginning while the language is
still a blur
uh or i might tag adverbs like i did a
fair amount of tagging by parts of
speech just to get a sense of how verbs
or adverbs or nouns work
but i mean in french you know it's a
noun what's a verb by and large so that
may not be necessary i think it depends
entirely on
on the language you may want to tag say
phrases where there's the feminine or
the masculine just to get again a
concentrated look at
how the gender works it depends it's
something that's there
uh i have used it more for some
languages than others and i use it more
at the early stage in a language when so
many things are unclear to me
and then what about the grammar guide
how often might you reference that
well um you know the languages that i've
been learning ever since we brought in
the grammar guide
uh i've been on languages where we don't
have a grammar guide
you know arabic
i would go there quite often
uh as an example
uh
context reverso offers verb conjugations
in
greek and i i also had a conjugating
dictionary for turkish so very often
when i looked at a verb i would then go
to the conjugation table
to see where this one is the one that i
selected and to quickly review the
conjugation table
because each each time you look at it
you know like the subjunctive or
whatever it's just
drip drip drip drip making you a little
bit more familiar with it uh but not
with the intention of trying to nail it
down
and i think our grammar guides i saw the
grammar guide in french it's very good
and you can essentially drill on
anything and i am
regularly curious about pronouns or
you know adjectives or verb tenses and
so to go there to look just in and out
go ahead look at it there's a brief
description of it there's no drills or
exercises uh and then you come back and
so it i think it helps you i think
that's very helpful i think to jump in
and out of the grammar guide is a good
thing to do
but unfortunately in the
languages that i've been doing that
hasn't been available to me
gotta work on that yeah yeah have you
been using the grammar guide
i have only read through it completely
once and then i looked at it just for
reference one other time because um
you know i'm starting to understand
through just
you know input right but the verb
conjugations in french are tricky
they're not the most intuitive and i
noticed you know the four four of the
most common verbs are irregular verbs
too which is super fun
um yeah i mean i can go to our grammar
guide i can also google stuff too i can
google romanian verbs
you know there are so many different
ways you can go to get that quick look
um and i would say with regard to
conjugations i would use the context
reverso there's also
there's the conjugating there's another
conjugating dictionary but context
reversal to me is the best
and every time i'm on a verb if i'm
struggling to get used to it whether in
spanish or french or italian or any
language like that go to the dictionary
just to have a quick look at it because
you're not going to nail it down you're
not going to study that list and nail it
down
but uh you know getting that occasional
snapshot of the conjugation tables i
have found to be helpful
yeah okay okay
all right so you know what i thought i'd
talk about today
uh before we get into
going through a lesson here because i
believe that that the language it's not
obvious what's difficult and what's easy
you know that what's in typically
chapter one is easier than what's in
chapter ten one of the things i was
thinking about this morning in french
that you may or may not have come across
for example is the use
is some of the pronoun issues by the way
i cut my finger this morning
my wife oh gosh
she makes this uh
sourdough bread and it comes in
different forms
and she makes baguettes she makes
loaves and she made this one batch of
baguettes that are so small
because it didn't rise properly and we
freeze them then i put them in the micro
for 15 seconds and try and cut it and
have to put it into the uh toaster oven
but it was so small and hard and frozen
that i my knife kind of slipped
on the baguette and cut my finger
so you know there is this word um have
you come across the word om
yes many times okay so i mean you that
again this is something you you get used
to through context but um
can mean
like it's one
it can mean
us
it can mean
you know one does this one does that in
english but it also can mean right you
know ques confe what are we going to do
today quest confett
is a very useful little word you've come
across it's general pardon
it's general right based kind of on what
the context is right okay i i've been
kind of understanding it the same way in
spanish you can say like in chile
it refers to
the people in chile but
i could also say like you know
when i'm talking about you and me right
exactly
exactly so yeah
it is like on the one says
yeah it is said right or one says but it
can also mean us
so it can also have that meaning all
right that's good then there's another
little word that pops up all the time
and that's oh
have you seen on is that a different
word
so
and there's another word the why
so he said ilyana there are ilyana
e just means there so there are iliya
of it
means of it so that's also a very useful
word
and so you're going to start noticing it
and
you might say for example
to
keska tom pass to on pause what do you
think of it keski tampons
or
the bread bread do you like bread it's
good german
jean
i eat a lot of it
so the ah
is a very very useful word so we got the
um
okay
i just mentioned that i just mentioned
that because i was thinking about it
this morning but you'll come across them
and of course the e is always there
ilyana
there are right
i thought that
meant there is or there are correct
where where
where does the on come in then
a bit
ilion
iliana
it's always comes
i have some i have of it jeanet
tiana
ilana that's i have of it and then
ileana
there are
you know uh
are there a lot of irregular verbs in
french we iliana
there are
okay
okay all right
anyway so um so
uh kind of useful little words
and it also helps you to nail that
pronunciation
okay
should we have a look at uh one of your
lessons have you uh have you been
listening to the mini stories fairly
regularly
yes just the ones that we've gone
through
already playlist i listen to him almost
every day yep okay so let's maybe have a
look
okay
all right
oh you're you've got a song there that's
my song lyrics
i'm happy to do this now
this is um by angel who's a belgian
singer who i discovered on spotify a
week or two ago she's belgian but she
sings in french and i really like her do
we look at this oh should we yeah
okay
people might be
i'm a great fan of the mini stories
because i like the repetition but i
admit that they can get a bit boring
okay so yeah i i i have to memorize
basically so should i go back to the
beginning or just start here whatever
you want to do
okay let's start at the beginning
because it's easier for me
she's got some repetition in this song
good i like this because the
pronunciation and the ex so read the
first sentence
you know this is a great sentence
because as i often say in french
especially for spanish speakers the uh
sound is very very important it makes
your french sound french wherever you
can introduce an oh
je vert
is you
good sorry good practice because you
gotta then alternate right
right yeah
and look at the s
drags on to the next word je voitige
right
because the i mean
so the y is considered a vowel
okay
all right next line
[Laughter]
sometimes it's hard to remember where
the uh comes in any e that doesn't have
an accent on it is uh
or one that doesn't isn't followed by an
s yes the s has the same effect but i
also all right your accent always often
suggests a missing s
the accent often suggests a missing
that's not a good rule because there are
other situations whatever you say in
language is always an exception or a
contradictory
okay
[Laughter]
because the x becomes a z
same as s it's liaison with the next
word
[Music]
perfect
next one
[Music]
this is a very good a little song to
practice your use
it really is i've been seeing with my
earbuds since i haven't actually heard
how i'm sounding
okay
all right
awful far there it doesn't mean of it on
is in
so only right
okay again
um
don't worry about it it's just you're
going to work on and work out and work
on it because language learning is a
matter of training the brain that's all
it is it's not a matter of understanding
something oh now i understand it now i
can do it it doesn't work that way
doesn't matter whether it's a structure
whether it's pronunciation it's all
practice it's not like instant wow now i
get it it doesn't work that way so you
just have and
yeah what i've noticed with speaking
with uh spanish is even if i have it all
in my brain if my mouth isn't accustomed
to like making the sounds and you know
speaking with the correct accent like
when i went to chile
it was my first time in a place where
they speak um with a very different
accent than in like mexico and costa
rica and more north north and um i had a
really good friend who was very honest
with me and she goes shelby you have to
work on your accent and i tried to
understand how could i work on my accent
and i realized i had to actually try to
mimic the way
the chileans would move their mouth and
tongue when they spoke and so the more i
train myself to do that by just doing it
um the easier and more natural it became
right
okay now let's try the final sentence
san santiago
very good so and here of course we don't
hear the s because it's followed by a
consonant
and
song a n
is on but salty is also
so these nasal sounds in french i mean
as i say you gradually particularly if
you get to a sentence where there's on
all in a row it's difficult and it's
only through constant practice but three
months from now you'll just be a lot
better at doing it doing it than you are
now so
okay
okay go to the next page
no this is i can't do this one
i can try i can try but
okay
okay i think i can do the first line
okay
okay
[Music]
okay
knock on skype for a while i know i
don't know
there we are
and what's that
i wait for your sign
and then
okay
what's happening there is so in french
j e is ger right so the missing e is uh
very often the uh disappears like even
at the end of a word like linear you can
pronounce it linear
but most most of the time we don't hear
uh it just goes
so it becomes sort of a neutral sound
that sort of disappears so sometimes
maybe to match the
the poetry here
instead of saying
he says
so that's something that you'll
encounter
you know like like you know in english
we sometimes gonna wanna
right so in french very often the uh
disappeared like we say je no se pa i
don't know
very often they just say ship up
here again proper french kilianapa that
as remember we spoke about the um
would be correct
you need the pa so you typically that
should
kill neonapa
but in the song and in everyday speech
so that the
has disappeared
okay that's the disappearing language of
french
this is
very good perfect
yay
um
[Music]
there you go that's it
you gotta practice
yes
you don't reply
uh but in common speech then disappears
okay
allah
[Music]
can we go in sentence mode here
oh sure
okay and show the translation because we
have had people saying what does it mean
oh right
okay so
uh yeah
right so this is easier so
georgetown
let's go back a page i just want to show
something
okay
so one of the problems with french
conjugation is when you say jaton
like i wait you wait he waits right they
all sound the same
but the first two have an s and the
second one doesn't have the third one
doesn't have an s
it's kind of the reverse of english
where the third person singular the
present tense takes an s
i go you go he goes
they're very often in french
jaton takes an s t takes an s e laton
no s
right so whenever you review your
conjugation
you'll see it's just a chance to review
that and all the different
forms of conjugation just to remind
yourself
but you'll still get it wrong but still
allah okay next page
let's give a lot of blue on this one
don't even know what i'm gonna be saying
can i translate it yeah please
i i find by the way when i'm going
through my arabic and persian
and i'm trying to decipher a sentence
and i'm always in sentence mode because
it's so difficult for me uh i like to
look at the translation it gives me a
better chance as i go through and i you
know
get the meanings of the individual words
yeah yes it's really hard to understand
a word in context when it's singled out
and sometimes it's perfect but
sometimes and a lot of the time it
really depends on the phrase and that's
why i really recommend that everyone
saves phrases not just
words
but you also need the words
you need to say yeah i'll like save a
phrase and i'll say like the words
within the phrase too as separate links
because
they'll be used in different ways but
the common phrases are very
helpful even like you're sharing these
common
little pronouns i guess or these little
articles that are um
used in so many different contexts
the the smaller the unit the more likely
it'll it'll repeat so if you save a word
it's likely to show up again if you save
a phrase that phrase may show up again
you know and of course you need to see
it often so so it's a good and therefore
i wouldn't some people like to save
whole sentences and i don't think that's
so good because sentences tend to be
more unique
whereas if you can get you know very
common phrases you'll see them again and
again
i'll show you as we go later through
this song there was one phrase that i
saved in this
and these lyrics that i can show you
guys that might be a good example you
want to jump to that or it's up to you
or do you want to go through these uh
see the words here
no i don't want to read this one
all right
um actually
let's see
okay we have to go through the chorus
again
i'm gonna go out of sentence mode for a
second
uh this one right so
fuller
yeah so you know crazy about you right
um and by the way
if we haven't heard the singer we don't
know up to this point if it's well maybe
there were some indications but whether
it's a guy or a girl but fold it why
it's a girl
because that's who is the masculine
uh-huh and i yeah i had heard that one
on a different
story
um and then like i understood this to
mean
um also of course this is like from the
first time we saw each other
no um here is is psy
huh
it's not scissors
from our first size
when they first met
they fell in love
so i said i understood that as love at
first sight no
no first time but
but that's very interesting because
we do jump to conclusions about things
yeah so we're conditioned you're
conditioned in english to love at first
sight so you
quickly
ignored the fact that there was no t
there it's of our
size well i do this all the time we make
assumptions we jump at it there's
nothing wrong with it yeah no totally
we'll need to unsave that one but i did
save this too by itself even though it
might not show up a lot but just like
understanding oh that's a good one
yeah
whether folder hold down the you know
i very much want that foo or full dir
crazy about doing something is very
common a good expression
but yeah i've heard it come up in my in
multiple different french lessons so it
sounds like something people say
now the the reason why we shouldn't
begin by saving phrases go and save the
word superior
okay
signing right
now you're not going to make the mistake
of thinking it's love at first sight so
i think it makes sense to save the words
first and then save the phrase
good lesson
yeah
i don't know why i don't already have
this one soon
i think you know plum yeah you know
right
yes yeah okay
well you know maybe we've gone for like
we don't want to go on too long i think
we've we've hit some things here i think
it's great that you're doing a song
and it introduces you to the sort of
more casual language where lots of stuff
is left out and
people who
i think it's very good to get the formal
structure because when you speak there
are situations where you have to speak
correctly and then there are situations
and then there are situations where you
can speak more casually so you need to
know what the correct structure is and i
think in that regard the many stories
are good
but if you then go out with a gang of
friends and they're all talking this way
it's also
have this uh
exposure too so that's great
yeah definitely
and maybe a nice mix
and and where did you get the song by
the way
well so um i was on spotify and i was
looking for french music i was referred
to you know another french artist and i
did the spotify radio option which is
great because it'll take it'll you know
introduce you to a lot of other artists
and songs that might you might also like
um i think the algorithm is great and so
i came across angel
her name is and i loved her sounds so i
started following her on spotify and i i
imported a few of her song lyrics
where'd you find the text
the lyrics yeah just quick google search
you know the song meme
and
um so yeah and of course you can
there's a
usually it's like on google right there
but if and i'll listen to it and i'll
read it on google and if it's if the
google
is is not um the correct translation
then i'll look at some of the top pages
because there's a lot of good
crowd-sourced
pages for lyrics can you show us uh here
first of all oh and if you found that
song on youtube you could actually
import and if it had subtitles you could
that's actually really true video of
that artist singing as well as the text
and the audio
but um
so that here's
just the lyrics you don't have it with
the audio if you had fun can you show us
on your phone where the uh
where the link uh browser extension is
to import
yeah do you want to go to youtube
as well first show me where if you can
show us where the browser extension is
so the browser extension i have this
little
this
bar going across here we go
um so here's the link extension right
here where did you get it on i've oh
yeah
okay well i just i mean it's on the
front page of the link site um but also
you can just easily google
link import extension and it'll be right
there yeah because some of uh maybe of
our our viewers don't know about the
browser extension don't know where to
find it and don't know how easy it is to
use
but we can use import literally anything
including youtube videos or text or
whatever
yeah in like two or three clicks it's
amazing how easy it is and even you know
a a long youtube video or even netflix
um you know you feel like it's a lot of
content that you're importing and it's
within a couple seconds
so yeah i hadn't thought about doing the
youtube videos but that's a good idea
this girl also makes very um
funny uh videos too so
one thing it'd be interesting to
experiment with uh when i import videos
from youtube they are time stamped and
when i go through the video like let's
say it's a ted talk in arabic or
something
uh it's time stamp so therefore when i'm
in sentence mode
i actually can hear the original sound
so
okay so it's not text to speech it's the
actual person speaking
so if you were to find the song i'd be
curious to know if you found this song
on
youtube and imported it and then went
through it in sentence mode whether you
could actually hear the person singing
for each sentence the actual
audio give that a try
that'll be really cool to experiment
with
yeah
okay because now i've just been
listening on spotify and
reading the lyrics at the same time but
yeah that's the level
one of the advantages of of getting the
audio into link
is that you then every time you listen
to it let's say it it'll automatically
go to your playlist every time you
listen to it you're getting credit for
listening so when you listen on spotify
in fact link is not tracking your hours
of listening
so
maybe next week we'll go through your
profile like you can see how you'll
track over the last weeks or even months
how much time you spent listening
reading and doing things on link and i
find it encouraging to see
you know at what period are we more
active less active so unfortunately
anything that's done outside of link you
can enter it manually but very few
people
so yeah in the end it's it's a good idea
to get it into link so that it'll track
automatically what you've been doing
yeah definitely it makes it just a lot
easier and they have it all in one place
exactly okay i think that's good you're
exploring that's what we want language
learners have to be explorers
okay yeah
well and and the last you know
important
thing that i was thinking about was with
music um
it really sticks i've met so many people
who have learned an entire language
mostly just through listening to music
in that language and looking at the
lyrics and of course it takes time and
dedication but because you can actually
sing along and you've got this like tune
that goes with it
you can remember it better and so i
wanted to try to like
um
implant things into my memory with a
little bit more force and experiment
with not just
you know many stories but exactly songs
and
um podcasts and all that good stuff
that's good and and the interesting
thing is with the song it introduces a
more casual form of a language which is
fun too yeah you have to do
yeah it's really cool
okay
allah you know what that means
no
la portion is
la proxima
in spanish
okay then to the next till the next time
until next time until next time
okay cool
okay
i can say uh
aviento
bye
[Music]
you